Speaker 1: OK, let's go next to. Where
are we going to go next? Let's go to.
Where are we going? Let's go
to Chris from Massachusetts,
who I believe is already unmuted
because they're a moderator, Chris,
from Massachusetts, you're on the air. Hey, David.
Speaker 4: Hello. Hey. So I posted this
just kind of puts it in the pack sales channel
was hoping to get some. Get your thoughts on this.
What do you think about? The Democratic
Party. It really started to embrace, well,
I'm not saying that they're doing this, but I
think it would be a good strategy of embracing
the politics in the policies of people like Katie
Porter rather than the squad. There seems to be
a. A cultural difference. But
obviously, there's a difference in how
Katie Porter and members of the squad approached
some of these cultural issues that are important.
Yes, but they also Katie Porter does a
really good job of, you know, holding
people accountable, especially in these
interviews that we've seen go viral
Speaker 1: on one hundred percent. Listen, I
think that there's two different things going
on here. You've correctly identified that
culturally. Katie Porter has a different.
Tone and approach to issues, then the squad,
and for me as a as an individual, I tend to like
Katie Porter's approach a lot. I tend to like it
a lot, but I think there's a more important piece
it has to be said. Katie Porter is
much more knowledgeable on a lot of
these issues than the squad types, and I'm
not saying it pejoratively. I'm just saying
Katie Porter has more experience, particularly in
the space of finance and economics, and she's more
knowledgeable. And so what I like the most about
the Katie Porter approach. It's less cultural for
me. It's more about she's just so knowledgeable
that you get the sense that she's not only crafted
a series of questions that will look a certain
way. She understands the issues in detail that are
underlying all of those questions. And I love the
Katie Porter approach. I think your idea is great.
Speaker 4: Yeah. And if you look at me,
she, you know. Was one of the few freshman
Congress people to flip or a historically red
district. Yes. And that seems like, you know,
when you look at the fact that the younger people
that tend to support, you know, the squad types
the most. They don't show up and vote. Mm hmm.
So the Democrats are kind of stuck with trying to
try to influence as much of the independents to
come out and vote for them as they possibly can.
Yeah. And I think and these cultural issues turn
off those independent types. But Katie Porter,
especially with her background in education, she
has like this, really. I mean, she's so skilled
at pointing out exactly how people's pockets are
getting picked up by, you know, banks. You know,
a lot of these, you know, property issues she was
going to. I mean, she was going to be, I think,
like a housing adviser for Elizabeth Warren. And
like you said, she's so knowledgeable on these
issues and she is just able to really communicate
to the people like this is how you are getting
worked over by the people in power. No,
no question about it. That really kind of
resonates with with across the spectrum and how
she was able to flip a district. So I think that,
you know, really the energy should AOC is
extremely popular. Ilhan Omar also popular, you
know, and they have their their place. But I think
like I think, you know, if we're going to put. As
the. We're going to put our resources into the
place where it's going to have the most impact,
it's getting behind people like Katie Porter.
Speaker 1: I agree. I think in the context of
the conversation about 2024 nominees, I don't
know that Katie Porter is is an appealing
nominee to a lot of people, but that's a
different question, and I think everything
you've pointed out is absolutely true.
Speaker 5: All right. Thanks, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you so much
for the call. Very, very good point.